m
oh surprise
le terrain
sachez que si maxime kenny n'a pas la
moyenne
il devra pendant la pub sur facebook
live faire d'études a vu à tout son
répertoire
je serai à votre côté voilà donc les
appels répertoire il vous ferez d'études
à vue voilà merci a été très sympa
attention des questions sur les invités
vous répondez vous avez votre petit créé
merci dans quelle série des années 80
marc lavoine at il fait ses débuts alors
à trois propositions comme la non je ne
sais pas d'accord tu as bossé c'est pas
la peine non mais non tu ne sais pas à
la fin des années 80 non mais tu peux
lire alors à marc et sophie masson
finances non marc n'importe quoi c'est
donc quoi pourtant c'est ce qu'a fait
beau ce qu'avait dit que j'allais
justement et au maroc s'était pas
qualifié pour ce café et on regarde puis
c'était en 1981 et marque peut-être tu
as toujours été bouge-toi non mais c'est
vrai non mais c'est vrai on regarde mais
j'aime bien la coiffure lance moment
impôts en l'air comme ça ben arfa hyper
bien je te regarder chanter tout à
l'heure il ya un débat jusque dupeyron
vous avez copié monsieur dupeyron vous
avez encore copier on remet vous copier
monsieur lui plairont et je veux vous
dire sur qui vous recopiez monsieur
luperon si monsieur fournol je suis à
monsieur pour nole messieurs pour noël
mais ont passé des vidéos qu'il a copié
[Applaudissements]
il ya des gens qui me dit au buteur le
pot marque lawani bien tranquille il a
demandé losail à benjamin castaldi
l'action le gars tranquille pour le dit
c'est vrai il est idées franchement
étonnant 82,85 capot est sorti en 92 80
c'était votre première télé vous faites
ça à temps vous aviez un petit rôle
vous jouez le rôle de l'élève pour nole
rappelé qu'il fumait des joints et qui
était qui se faisait virer de l'école
est exactement mais c'est vrai et il
aimait déjà j'aime bien je le père était
alcoolique
c'est dingue parce que l'histoire était
sympathique et la levure attention sur
quelle chaîne thomas sotto at il fait sa
première télé mais je sais teva canal j
ou dorcel tv avec canal du canal jacques
est exactement vous êtes vous aviez vous
faisait le jt sur canal j j'étais pour
enfants exactement on a pris un peu de
retard et le ping pong c'est le premier
de revoir des images
si non enfin si si et vous aviez déjà au
beau si on regarde par les élèves de 6e
et de 5e
cette dizaine d'élèves nous a reçus
alors qu'ils sont en vacances ils sont
venus exprès pour nous et ils nous ont
donné leur avis sur l'actualité parmi
les sujets qui les ont intéressés
[Applaudissements]
placé en 97 47 88
franchement y'a rien à ajouter un gars
mais peut-être la chemise les cheveux ça
va changer du tout non plus ça commence
à m'inquiéter
ac c'est censé mieux maintenant olivier
et mieux maintenant toi de toi tu t'es
tombé du toit pourra quitter sochaux
moi je suis plutôt assez wells confirme
oui c'est vrai
le standard est beau mais vous allez
voir le pôle on peut aussi en complément
chanteur marc lavoine a été pris d'un
fou rire dans une émission d'olivier
minne à propos d'un gâteau réalité le
gâteau un gland un cake ou un fillon
d'un cake et ouais c'est un extrait du
branchement en audiologie blanc vois tu
ce chiffre marque pas souvent des fous
rires en télé avec olivier j'en ai
beaucoup il est formidable on la
laissera or d'énergie beaucoup parce
qu'en fait il est il faut pas rigoler je
l'adoré une regard des simples comme la
tienne
mais ces deux cd moulé cdm où les sons
qui est plus difficile avait son rebond
après on mélange qui est assez longtemps
les cas marque oui je vais essayer de
latouille en mai lendemain comptez pas
sur moi pour le dénommé par l'appareil
est homogène le voilà bien le mélange
avec les oeufs au mélange le tour pardon
pendant que tu vas le faire en fait jean
luc moi je vais vous quittez un court
instant
mais bien sûr vous allez faire le généré
c'est tout simplement d une autre
émission avec l'olivier gundam avait une
sorte de truc pour les voitures ouais
bah oui aravane reste est noir comme ça
avec une grosse boule au bout ça on est
moche sur ces thèmes
c'est quoi on l'a aussi bon là aussi ça
irrésistible sarsgaard accord et
qu'olivier à chaque fois c'est un
attelage une boule d'attelage
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle c'est que la boule d'attelage
une fois qu'elle est montée et bientôt
la démonter faut prendre des outils faut
prendre toutes sortes de choses et c'est
extrêmement pénible du tout et on
s'était dit ça serait bien de pouvoir la
démonter cette doute parce qu'on s'en
sert pas tout le temps et lordon et
l'affairé s'est pour l'instant vous ne
pouviez pas le faire surtout pour cent
c'est en général que deux trois fois pas
là maintenant c'est possible
une seul inconvénient c'est qu'il faut
quand même avoir le système d'attaché
non y'a quand j'ai fait mouche
[Applaudissements]
on voit peut-être les vaisseaux ont bien
changé c'était à l'époque surtout pour
le premier extrait on avait honte c'est
parce qu'on construit comme une faute
professionnelle d'avoir un fou rire à
l'antenne c'est ont essayé de masquer
possible d'assumer tout vous avez cassé
les codes vous ne savez même à l'époque
j'avais caché caché la forêt y avait
plein de fous rires à l'essai mais
contenir ont tous les parigots nbc je
vous ai dit vers ça trop de filles ont
dû dire ça c'est grâce à vous j'ai pu y
assister
pleinement merci beaucoup chef
enfin qu'il a mis 50 idées dans la même
phrase extrêmement plaisir de vous mais
moi aussi mais bonjour à la chaîne je
comprends pas question sur complément
d'enquêté sur didier deschamps ce sera
ce soir sur france 2 pour quels types de
produits didier des shows at il fait une
publicité de l'eau minérale et biscuits
août ça a beau l'avoir vu des biscuits
des biscuits c'est pour quelques
biscuits aux plus futiles fallait pas
lire la mare hazen et la crds de dollars
merci vous êtes très beaux messieurs
j'adorais mc la bosse qui est intervenu
en direct de la cre un jet de la
regarder
le shit didier deschamps lui ne sera
qu'une seule publicité est trop
alors le brésil où ils sont et comment
on les mangeait action alors le match on
va les [ __ ]